(guitar music)
- [Cassandro] In the dressing
room something happens
while I'm getting ready.
Once I start putting my makeup on,
I turn from this male
to female.
And that is amazing for me.
(crowd cheering)
My name is Cassandro El Exótico.
I am a professional wrestler;
I've been wrestling for 28 years.
I'm an Exótico Luchador,
which is a flamboyant,
a wrestler with glamour and style.
(crowd chanting "Cassandro")
(cheering)
I always knew I was different.
I remember when I was in second grade,
I think I was like seven
or eight years old.
And I already knew I was gay.
I was taught that I couldn't be gay,
I couldn't act this way,
I couldn't dress this way,
I couldn't talk this way
because I was going to burn in Hell.
When I was first called to be an Exótico
I was like, "Wow, freedom."
This weight that I'd
been carrying for years
was just like melted down.
Rhinestones, rhinestones, rhinestones.
Glow in the dark.
I started using the pantyhose, the makeup,
the bathing suits,
rhinestones, feathers,
and boas and all that
because I wanted to be different.
And that was the scariest moment,
but when I saw the audience and the fans,
how they took me in,
they were just like "Wow,
look at him, her, she."
I feel like a woman inside.
And then it's like this is me.
And that transformation is beautiful.
Something happens when I get out
of the dressing room to the ring.
I'm still looking like a
woman, I'm looking flamboyant,
and then once I step in the ring,
my macho side kicks in
and I'm like "You gotta
be ready for the fight."
(slapping)
(yelling)
All my title matches and
mostly all of my matches
has been against men.
Masked men, machista's, homophobics,
and I vow always being true to myself.
It's lucha libre, not a beauty parlor.
Even though it looks like it sometimes.
Today I can tell you
that being gay
has been a gift from God to me.
And I understand that.
So that's why lucha libre has always been
one of my biggest medications.
I don't think I will
ever leave lucha libre.
This is what I've done all my life.
(crowd cheering)